So now that we've learned, a bunch of new words
related with classes and objects, we will move on to
creating a movie website. And here is the final output
that we are after. All of our favorite movies, on a
web page. And as you have seen previously, if you
click on anyone of these movies, we see its trailer.
Let's build this. So here I am, back with my
code. Now thus far, we've made only two movie objects. Toy
Story and Avatar. I'm going to make a few more.
In fact, four more movie objects. But before I do
that, I want to make this window, a little bit
bigger, so we can see all of this code really easily.
Okay. So here are the two instances we have created
thus far. Toy Story and Avatar. Now before I proceed, I
will go ahead and comment ou the previous output statements
that I created. This print statement and the show trailer method.
So let me just add a comment there,
and there. Done. Now, I'm going to add
a new movie object, for a movie called, School
of Rock. There it is. You will notice, that
I have changed the name of the movie,
its story-line, its poster image, and its future trailer
values appropriately. Next, I will add another movie object.
This time, for an animated movie called Ratatouille. Next,
I will add a movie object called, Midnight in
Paris. Now this, happens to be one of my
favorite movies. And the final movie object I will
add, is for a movie called, the Hunger Games.
Okay, so thus far, we have created six movie
objects. So far, so good. Now, to turn this
into a movie website. You will need a piece
of code that weed out. Now we call this code,
fresh_tomatoes.py. By the way, this file is available
for you to download in the instructor notes. Now
before we use it, let's see what this
file actually does. This file, fresh_tomatoes.py, has a function
inside it called, open_movies_page. Let's look at this
function a bit more closely. Now, what this function
does, is that it takes in, a list of
movies as input, and as output it creates and
opens an HTML page or a website, that shows
the movies you gave it in the first place.
So what I'm going to do next, is use
this file, fresh_tomatoes.py, and it's
function, open_movies_page, inside our code.